[Music]
what are the benefits of frequent short
walks versus ones that are fewer with
longer intervals hmm that's great well
your body is
so this would come back to
a lot of research one particularly would
be a researcher called joan vernicos
from nasa um she was there she was
studying the health of astronauts in
space for something like 40 years i've
also done a podcast with her as well um
and she what she found with astronauts
was having
regular bouts of movement was vastly
more supportive for the health and
wellness of the astronauts than doing
like blow out
you know super workouts
for two hours and then just floating
into an infinity for the rest of the day
so
think of your body your body you know
essentially ultimately your body is a
bunch of water bags yes right that's
what your muscles are it's what your
organs are like most of you're just a
bunch of water being contained by
connective tissue which is also mostly
water yeah you know and so i've heard
i've heard zach bush dr zach bush even
talk about how he he has a theory that
our memories are stored in the water in
our bodies not in our brain yeah it gets
into like
like the emoto the emoto stuff of um
thoughts and different types of music
and sensation and like the sensation of
love compared to hate changing the the
water the crystalline structure of water
that's right particularly when it gets
frozen um there's also contention around
the stuff i don't know but probably it
feels right
you know um well what was i talking
about i got excited about this
i interrupted we're talking about
walking and walking yeah so so you're a
bunch of water bags
you know so if you if you were when i
was a kid i told you you're a water bag
thank you
when i was a kid i wanted to be a
landscape architect so i was building
ponds i was big big big pond guy uh what
a great like passion to cultivate anyway
i was all about it yeah i would just sit
by my pond in my backyard like for hours
it was so great and there was frogs it
was like a whole thing it's good
but the way that you have a healthy pond
is you have a a pump that's adequate to
fit the amount of gallons of water in
that pond
right so that's the first thing and then
you have that waterfall going freaking
all the time oh you don't just a healthy
pond isn't just like one like
like blow out just put some pool shock
in there every once in a while
and it's not stagnant either right
you know so a healthy pond has regular
circulating movement yeah right so in
your body a healthy cell which is pretty
much a pond you know or a healthy organ
has regular manual
twisting turning
up down in out it just gets these subtle
little massages throughout the day and
so when there's the the buildup of old
stagnant fluids it says okay building
building building ah release
the way that you circulate lymphatic
fluid
is through muscular contraction
so if you are standing for a while
you're sitting on a plane you start to
get cankles and you have this buildup of
lymph and all of a sudden your ankles
look like big and ugly you know ugly is
a relative where it's subjective i
apologize for that but they look big
distasteful for most most people's
subjective lens
um
you know that's literally a buildup of
this fluid that if you had just
turned the waterfall on
and done a little circulation you'd
never have that backing up so you can
visually see it
in your ankles
that's also happening
everywhere else internally
so just a little walk
is such a beautiful thing because it's
like think if you have a rag and it's
got some gunk on it you clean some stuff
off of the counter and then you want to
rinse the rag out
the way that you rinse the rag out is by
you put some water on it and you twist
the rag and then you maybe shake it out
a little bit and i was going to steal
some gunk you put some water you twist
the rag
that is walking
right so that contralateral motion
contra opposite lateral side every time
i walk
my right hip extends back my right
shoulder comes back and then i
elastically sling myself into the next
position
that literally all of my organs all of
my connective tissue is going through
that spiral rotation twisting out the
old gunk to bring in the new healthy
fluid
that is health
and as little as 10 minutes 15 minutes
like whatever you can do what have you
done
so so my suggestion with like with you
know the align method isn't so much well
in the in the program we break down more
specific actions you know what people
can do but the book as a whole is more
of a philosophy on how you engage with
your body yeah it's not particularly
prescriptive which i really appreciate
although there are exercises that help
you really essentially establish a
deeper understanding i would never have
to go to a three-year-old
and say here are the squatting exercises
that you need to do because they would
look at me like i'm already squatting
what are you talking about this isn't
even an exercise yeah but we've gotten
so far away from that that you are
essentially aligning us back to where we
were when we went back to just being a
four-year-old yeah you know but with a
car
that's it yeah
and so but the uh so with the walking
for example the same way the pull-up bar
just it's like you know a pull-up bar
invites you to hang it's like you almost
didn't need to do anything it's just
being there
almost unnoticeably you're just kind of
like oh like my arms are over my head
yeah like
i did a little swing
it wasn't like a do you have to like
motivate
it was there you did it right you know
and so with the walking thing one of the
healthiest things a person can do for
themselves start to organize your
meetings around taking a walk
if you have a bunch of calls say cool
i'm going to get out of my office on
whatever floor i'm on you know and
behind these windows that are blocking
out a percentage of the of the the
spectrum of light yes you know and i'm
breathing in this this
processed
air from the air conditioning and the
deionized air and i'm bombarded by emf
and like all this different stuff it's
not bad
you just it's just nice for your body to
have the opportunity to go out and take
a little break and just like absorb
nature
for one minute five minutes 30 minutes
an hour yes and a beautiful time if you
have a call
you know a meeting whatever it is start
to make the culture of your business
be more of like oh we're like a healthy
culture yeah it's 2020 too
like a part of the culture a part of our
brand is we do things better yeah a part
of doing things better is we care about
the health of the people that we work
with
a part of that is we need access to some
nature yeah so
when we're doing our meeting just a
simple simple thing we'll be like hey
you want to just like walk around the
block and talk about this stuff yeah so
maybe if there's a grassy area you could
take your shoes off yeah do a little
grounding some grounding yeah all that
stuff so it doesn't need to be this wily
okay now your vivo barefoot five finger
toe guy and yeah you know you're doing
like a like a deep lunge in the middle
of like a wedding scenario it's like
you're hanging out of trees like you can
do all that stuff but it does not need
to be
like a heretic situation you don't need
to be that crazy guy yeah like you can
seamlessly infuse health-inducing
lifestyle choices
without being this wily heretic yeah
like you're just creating little moments
during the day just a little bit to be
with nature it's interesting so i had
covered a couple weeks ago
and um everyone's everyone's sphincters
clench up a little bit all right
no i'm totally fine now but you know to
get some air moving through the house we
open up
our doors and like kind of creates this
little wind tunnel yeah and it's amazing
like
so we keep the house at about 72 or 73
whether it's heat or air conditioning
right like that's just kind of where it
usually falls with me and my wife
i open up the doors turn the air off
because you know pointless at that at
that point
and i remember sitting there i'm like
man it feels really good in here it was
like 78 degrees
and i'm like it feels great
and it was in it was just interesting
because i'm like i don't know what
the natural air like how that i'm easily
i get easy uh it's easier for me to
acclimate towards a 78 or 77 degree
temperature than when the doors are
closed like it's got to be 72 or 73 i
don't know what that means but i just
found it fascinating where i was sitting
down i'm like oh wow like we should keep
the doors open more often because this
feels great and then i look at the
thermostat and it's
yeah it was definitely over 75 degrees
and i'm just like oh wow like this feels
better than the 72 degrees that we
usually keep it at that's interesting i
don't know why that would be exactly i
don't know either yeah but anyway part
of that goes back to what you're talking
about earlier the stories we tell
ourselves right like it's supposed to be
72 degrees in order for me to be
comfortable right and i mean i think
there's we could like extrapolate some
random random
seemingly disparate connections that
might somehow make sense with that like
one one example is um having access to
nature with particularly this was done
in um pennsylvania university of
pennsylvania with it was they were
studying patients in the hosp in a
hospital post gallbladder surgery
and the uh they were studying people
that had access to a window to be able
to see out and just like see some trees
you know just basic like i could just
see outside yeah versus people that
didn't have access to being able to just
see outside and what they found is
people that having access to nature just
visually looking like like the nature is
just touching their eyes
like that they're not even in the nature
who's just touching their eyes
um they have they need less
uh pain medication so their tolerance to
pain increases um and they ended up
being released from the hospital i think
it was on average two days earlier
that's amazing so just you touching the
eyes with your or the nature with your
eyeballs yeah like you don't even need
to be in the nature right it's just you
know it's there yeah it literally causes
your body to upregulate and say like i
think everything's gonna be okay wow
that's cool and so perhaps there could
be some connection in that of like okay
i touched the nature with my eyes
you're touching the nature with your
your other senses yeah right skin you
know you're you're hearing the nature
you feel different you're like an air
conditioned air
i'm not like i don't have a lot of depth
on this so i don't want to [ __ ] but
it does something to the air deionizes
the air it's like makes it like less
nutritious in a way talk to somebody who
knows more about that yeah but it makes
the air more garbage yeah i could i can
shorten it yeah well no i know like
compared to going outside compared to
like that sensation of breathing air by
a waterfall
like
there's a different imprint in that yes
like you walk along the beach and you
take a breath in
yeah
i apologize for not having the science
to give you like this this amazing
in-depth explanation of that there's a
but just feel into it with yourself yeah
there's a difference there and there's
somebody else that has more research
about that yeah if you want to look it
up yourself let me see if i can like
yeah look into that because there's
something like with the ac in my car
versus the windows down it's a different
feeling there's a different visceral
feeling that happens
yeah
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com slash the minimalists
or click the link in the description
your support keeps our podcast and
youtube channel one hundred percent
advertisement free